tastes like if the Imam has two jobs you
can't pick you up from school you come
home and watch Pokemon and eat something
like this I've had veggie burgers before
and some of them are really good and
some of them are really bad I like the
ones where you can see the vegetables
inside of them rather than the ones that
pretend to be me so I don't want
something that tastes like a hamburger I
want something that's like this
delicious veggie patty you should do you
veggie burgers no me garden burgers are
the first veggie burgers I ever had
cheers Cheers I feel like I taste some
mushroom in there I'm a little bit
weirded out but I don't hate it
I think the condiments would help a
little bit I'm definitely one pulling
cheese lettuce tomato on it a little
sriracha pepper on it yeah a little
grandma's little pepper sauce there are
much better veggie burgers than this
well ever seen this but it is called
Hillary's evil the world's best veggie
burger looks like a quinoa White Castle
gluten-free corn for yeast free dairy
free soy free egg free not free what
what else is left no it's really dry it
has a texture of quinoa but I don't
taste quinoa which i think is a good
thing from one Hilary to another do
better this is a lie don't trust them
John tells favorite morning sir
Morningstar is great if you go to like
any fast food place that happens to have
veggie burgers or anything
Morningstar they always called
Morningstar
I went straight into a potato mm-hmm
this is like we made like the Macdonald
stuff that my palate is like the
resurrected in the last burger
I could see buying this especially if it
was like on sale as its own patty I
would endorse it
beast burger so this is veggie burgers
format ooh 23 grams of protein smells
like barbecue sauce got the grill lines
on it and everything
oh it tastes like what I would imagine
dog food it tastes like this one
definitely isn't trying to do its own
thing it's just trying to mimic a beef
burger what a weird thing I kind of like
it it's hurting like yeah in size I'm
eating the whole thing I really like
your teeth like sinks until you're like
okay this can actually be pretty good
but we are tongue hits it's like oh no
it's not me though this could be the
best one if I didn't have a tongue oh oh
it's a masala burger Bala you can
definitely see a lot of edges in this
one like whole pieces of corn and potato
mm this one's killer oh that's good it's
flavorful
this is the best one no and again you
can see what's in it I might be able to
see what's in it oh and the other thing
I like about this is the spices are
strong enough to get rid of the Beast
burger taste in my mouth it just tastes
like a potato patty yeah this is cool
I'm into it it's done right you didn't
go to Joe's yeah Trader Joe's killed it
and we both like the masala burger a lot
yep definitely the best one I think this
is the best this is my choice you like
mornings I like morning sir
you combine the flavor of the masala
yeah and the texture of the morning star
the packaging yeah and the packaging oh
it's a winner usually it's just like
what veggie burger option is they're
like oh my god you have a veggie burger
thank you so much it's so considerate of
you